you think he's the midfielder in it
scots i genuinely thought paul's cause
i really did like that on there
he said post goals
why how he had no pace he was dead small
he wasn't that he wasn't that good yeah
he couldn't tackle to save his life and
still he's regarded as the best if not
one of the best so how did how do you
that that shows your argument you said
he doesn't have all that best
at best
he's not he's not better than lampard
and he's not better than jeff
[Music]
oh mate how you doing good
good to see you
how are you i'm yeah decent yeah you
how's the football well treating you
fussy's good isn't it it's not bad
it's not bad we've
gone for a bit of a transition but
rebuild yeah quality this is like one of
those if it's a long rebuild to build
one of those nightmare homes
well i need some advice actually to be
fair because you know when you go on
baron spells and long time about winning
things and i need i need that i need
that support so this is good don't worry
i've got this is therapy for me to be
yeah cristiano ronaldo will leave a
better premier league legacy than most
sellers
three
two
one
oh
how old wait hol how old well first of
all
oh wait no yeah christina yeah this all
depends on whether you give him his
contract and he stays 100 because if he
if you don't and you don't just give him
this empty contract and get him to put
whatever number he wants on it which is
what you should do
then the answer is
this yep
however
it hurts me but if if mo salas stays
another four years and signs his
contract and wins the league another
couple of times and stuff he's in a
massive conversation if saller
signs a contract extension i think he
could end up as one of the all-time
all-time mount rushmore premier league
great if he only does this season the
next he'll be a premier league great i
think his legacy will be a big premier
league legacy because his time in italy
won't be anywhere near as substantial as
what it is
but i think ronaldo
was still a young man in the premier
league initially and albeit a very very
good achievement so much
true true but i think but i think he's
far more known
as a real madrid player i think he's got
a far bigger la liga legacy i don't
think ronaldo's premier league legacy is
as big
um
as maybe it feels because there's a man
united fan because you hold them so dear
i can see i can see that point and i
hear that point a lot and i feel like
i understand that but with what he
achieved he got his first ballon d'or
man united because his level is so high
and then he went on to real madrid
to do extraordinary things for a really
long period of time what he achieved at
man united as a young kid who hadn't
even reached his peak yet gets forgotten
about yeah and that in terms of a
premier league legacy to ri on reid
didn't even win the ballon d'or when he
was there mo salah hasn't won the ballon
d'or as being the best ronaldo did it
when he wasn't even in his peak
and for me
that sets above what what a special
player he was won the champions league
as well fa cup you know league cup he's
and three premier leagues in a row do
you think there's a chance that in
coming back actually though
harms that legacy um i'm one of these
fans that say once you've written
something it's done so like every single
song about steve and jedi falling over
[Applause]
yes there we go okay of course i of
course have okay every man united fan
has okay um but when you achieved what
cristiano ronaldo achieved like i was
just saying at a young age going up to
the level that he was before he went to
um real madrid
i don't think that can be undone
especially because i look at things like
age is catching up with it
like you know time waits for no man and
it's sometimes it's sad to see but he's
still our top scorer still got us
through the champions degree stage where
no one else would have so there's still
elements of it where it's catching up
with him i understand that but no
tonight's question no yeah because the
only issue with that is of course is
what you do when he's no longer able to
contribute because we'll know that it's
the job yeah he's sad to see but it's
the general thing we have that we had
how did you phase
he's got a far bigger premier league
legacy than cristiano ronaldo was by an
absolutely well you've got the longest
manchester united all-time top scorer
england's all-time reign is the best
thing
as people remember wayne rooney when he
got a bit a bit slow and a bit fast and
went back to everton and now look at him
he looks about 75 years old i mean like
this question is not even about wayne
rooney wayne rooney is the best english
player ever
okay that's not even a question sorry
yeah put that in the title yeah that's
what wayne rooney is yeah that's what
ray rooney is currently
no manchester united players would make
it into liverpool's starting eleven
three
two
one what happens if i leave my cup where
it is
what does that mean you're just going to
tip it over
if you have to choose
you've got to go one way or the other
okay i'm amazing friends i've got to do
this
and i'll tell you why
okay because there's not many oh there's
not many
if
bruno fernandez played under jurgen
klopp
and could show him that he could conform
to the way that klopp would like to play
football yeah imagine the likes of bruno
fernandez supplying the likes of marnie
supplying the likes of salah yeah lewis
diaz etc etc yeah that's one thing
the second thing is this and this is the
last thing because i feel you're gonna
run away with this one okay right but
i'll be honest yeah
if cristiano ronaldo was in liverpool's
team as a number nine and was told by
jurgen klopp listen ronnie
you stay within the width of the 18-yard
box yeah everybody else will do the rest
kind of what would have happened if he
went city ronaldo would score 25 to 30
goals of liverpool there's a lot of
caveats there it's like if your club was
fundamentally born and raised a
completely different human being yeah
and had a totally different managerial
style yeah basically he wasn't clock if
he wasn't you know you can drop that
different manager all together then
maybe you know yeah because i see this
all the time i see this with like um
pogba yeah i think pogba is
powerful like the most yeah talented
footballer man united i think of up
there with ronaldo
and because he's way better than
henderson but
would clock with the with how with the
functionality exactly and the reason why
you can go by easy is because of the
functionality of henderson in your squad
yeah would henderson leave that
functionality of squad and have that
type of impact over any other team i
don't believe it i don't think he'd have
i don't think anyone would have had any
doubts over the whether he's good enough
or not yeah with john anderson if he was
at manchester united
whereas it's like it must be tiresome
the pogba stuff you're watching for five
seconds you're on a footballer yeah and
then you're watching for 20 minutes
you're like what
are you telling me that jordan henderson
is better than bull pogba i think he's a
better premier league footballer than
paul pogba no one's had to debate over
the last five years about jordan
henderson's value to liverpool football
club and liverpool have been at the
absolute peak of football whereas you've
had five years of conversation saying
how do we unlock paul pogba what does
paul pogba need do agree with that and
one the the comment that i would say i
wouldn't say that he's a better
footballer than than paul pogba because
he like he said he's not but
would i say he's more consistent yes
because
jordan henderson will put up sevens and
eights consistently every week and paul
pogba will give you a five then give me
an eight then maybe even give me a nine
ten then go back to being a five so the
consistency aspect but in terms of who
i'd rather have in my team right now
with what we've got
i believe that we need paul pogba
more than i need a jordan henson one
might i suggest that you might want to
try the other thing because that thing's
clearly not working well he's going to
leave him
back to my other player
rafael varan now you're going to tell me
that joel matip is criminally underrated
outside of the liverpool fanbase because
you guys are the best center for nelly
drink more drink and can we get some
more celebratory
rafael varan and this and and here's
where you got him out a little bit
because it isn't necessary because
you're about to make a defensive case
for why he's not done it for man united
no no man united is a is a broken
institution and he's only been there
since the beginning of this year when
rafael varan has played at manchester
united he's been absolutely brilliant
he's been fine many united fans will
tell you that i know you're going to go
john mata because you've seen it he's
one step but you cannot tell me with
raphael varane's
prowess and what he's achieved in his
career as a center half even over van
dijk he is a top top draw center half
and he could get into he's better than
kanate he's better than um joel matt and
if you had van dyke and varane you would
be even better i think if i had to
accept
you're gonna rafael varan
would live with it you know
all right look at all the european cups
absolutely fine i've got a bad brand's a
gay player but
what's the point he's not an upgrade on
mata he's not better better that he's
not better than joel
i think he is in
do you look at one and go you know what
i think you'd be right who makes the
best cup of tea
because he's a wonderful human being and
he would fit in with the ethos of our
squads okay so it's not a football
living really it's not funny i think
he's really good the football as well
klopp's title winning team
is better than any team united have had
three put mine on the floor one
off the table mate
klopp's title winning team was better
than any man united team has ever been i
don't even understand how it's a
question like how how how what might
what attack this has been so good and
we're getting here here and you do this
well this is why they've done this to us
tell me
and all of you in public what is
manchester united's best ever title
winning team you could have the 99
treble if you want you can have the 08
team if you want
either of those two i'm happy with
because though because those two are the
all-time great of premier league teams
if you whichever one you want to put in
one or two the treble winning team is
untouchable
untouchable what it takes to get up and
go again yeah and get up and go again
and not do the treble that you did
that poor man's treble to do the real
treble no one's ever done it before the
reason why no one's ever done it before
is because that is the greatest domestic
achievement you can possibly do and any
team that achieves that i.e only man
united they are the best premier league
team
in history but if we're talking about
pure premier league team yeah
there's not a premier league season that
man united have put down that comes
close you guys didn't even get the most
points ever still got more than one
united have ever got even the season
when liverpool came second
on 97 points united i haven't even had a
premier league season not good but you
didn't win yeah
so you were a loser manchester united
you just told me there's a season where
the loser could be better than the
winner this is not me going arsenal
invincibles
70 games
this is me saying that liverpool got 97
points in the season which is a higher
tally than manchester united have ever
achieved in premier league history man
united are the most successful premier
league team of all time they rightly
held up
what the team never put a season right
yeah but that's but that's
circumstantial and this is the place
i don't mean just in that season i mean
the dominance in the period of what it
was so man united have done like three
back-to-back titles
couple of times liverpool yeah okay
you're up against the mighty city and
all that but who are you
the best the best football team in the
premier league has ever seen
is this about man city
because i disagree with that as well
okay i can't sit here and say that that
99 team wasn't absolutely incredible
just saying it wasn't but i'll just say
it as far as a premier league team in a
38-game season united
did you know what this is a team
game season down better than liverpool's
night you know you've got one premier
league title right but 19 retails the
cheek of having one premier league the
one one that you won and you're just
saying that's just the topples all the
ones that we want with you kind of down
playing
the treble and how good it was and you
done the poor man's version of it my
question to you is do you think you'll
be able to do the real one the real
trouble is i think it's as likely in the
next two years as it's ever been i think
liverpool i've got the best squad i've
ever seen one piece of silverware in the
bag already
which wouldn't count towards your
trouble
it's already the start it's the start of
the poor man's trouble would have
thought or maybe it's the start of the
quadrupling note
it's the start of the season but we just
win the league when we go back into our
hole paul scholes was a better player
than steven gerrard knew it knew it i'd
take yours
get away
he was fine like paul scholes he was
absolutely fine
[Laughter]
that he was he did all right he was just
he was
he was not knocking him back what is
this you are steven gerrard or his
favorite central midfielder is he'll
tell you his postcards and paul's goals
to tell you as himself
that's it you asked your favorite
midfielder's favorite midfielder who
they don't ask me
do you should send this these questions
to javi zedan and piero they'll tell you
they'll tell you
dan would have said that was the austere
senator
there are things that stephen gerrard
could do
that paul scholes couldn't do
i understand that i think but gerard
could do everything the paul scholes
could do apart from win in a fancy dress
competition
he could bake bean
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but gerard could do more on the pitch he
was a complete midfielder and it's
always unfair in these conversations i
think because
goals was effectively a forward you know
i mean his early days and he played
exactly exactly with his jedi played
everywhere i do feel like gerard's game
is
had more
elements to it but i feel like because
paul's skulls were so good at what he
did when you're that good it's like
saying
don't need the rest
don't need the rest i'm so good at this
yeah that i don't need to be good in a
tackle i am never
ever
gonna sit anywhere and say that that
gerard is better but i can understand
the argument of why someone would say
gerard is but he's not i think jared was
the best player in
in in every liverpool side he played in
i would make a case to pause goals with
never gerald plays with bloody aquilani
and people like that would you
this is this is a shell but i don't know
where did you fall apart
you know you've got your key you've got
carrick as the top ones you play with
nikki butt top top drawer player nikki
bart's the top doctor player yeah in
that era not a lot of respect gets put
on him yeah but what i'm saying is is
that he was always surrounded by top
players yeah you can't put this
argumentation that gerard david was
always the best player in the team oh
nikki when you've had we'll look at you
bruno shay room and play players like
that true gerard was always the best
because he was believing
yeah but even yeah but true enough
was probably the best parent yeah and
and to be fair he had some good players
alongside him but you're right it's
that's he was always going to be i can
never disassociate myself from stephen
jeddah yeah and of course being just the
role model in terms of like you wanted
to grow up you could go you could be
stephen gerard because he's he's like
he's a local boy and he's got a lot of
stuff and skulls obviously got back home
for united as well but yeah i
it's one i don't expect any liverpool
fan you could you ever say that scholes
is better like if it scolds gerard
lampard i'm always skulls understandable
and the chelsea fans always land part of
liverpool fans of each other yeah
you think he's the midfielder in it
scots i genuinely thought paul's cause
i really did like
that
he said post goals
why how he had no pace he was dead small
he wasn't that he wasn't that good
yeah he couldn't tackle to save his life
and still he's regarded as the best if
not one of the best so how did how do
you that that shows your argument you
said he doesn't have any match best
at best
he's not he's not better than lampard
and he's not better than gerard
[Laughter]
why didn't you put michael carrick
instead of a set of skulls he thinks
oh my god
liverpool will win the champions league
again
before united even qualify for it
three
two one
oh my
um
oh
don't even want to move my cup man
liverpool will win it before so really
if you win it this season and we
finished fifth which could easily happen
yeah that's this over
how how i i'm gonna go i'll go like i
believe
yeah i have to back my team i'm here
so
i'm here i've gone back my team i've got
about one team we will qualify for the
champions league this year by winning it
[Laughter]
yeah wait when does this even go
because right now it's one one and it's
finally in the balance with me so as we
record as as this goes out we might not
be in it i don't like i'll be honest
like i i i'm on dangerous ground because
you can't can't say you're gonna you're
more
yeah exactly you should finish top four
exactly but you can't say you should win
the champions league so join me to just
put that back i'm going to keep it there
liverpool versus united is still the
biggest game in the premier league
three two one
there's probably a few city fans who'll
be rolling their eyes at this point but
no the the one there's like two fixtures
that i look out for every single season
it's the major side derby yep and it's
liverpool this manchester united because
that is the biggest game it's the two
biggest football clubs two most historic
football clubs
the biggest most aggressive rivalry
amongst them as well
that is it's up there it's there it's up
there with del clasico it's up there
with anything called on any world
without 100 exactly my thing with this
is is actually
it's not the best quality game anymore
because we quite enjoyed old trafford
this season yeah yeah i bet you did but
if you ask people outside the fan base
as neutrals
and it pains me to say it and i've seen
the games this season they want to see
city against liverpool they're the two
best teams them games are high octane
liverpool against chelsea two top
managers two top teams go the quality of
football is better but however in terms
of the history of the fixture and what
it means to these two sets of fans
that's still our biggest game liverpool
and city i think is a it's a it's a fad
it's
the reason why you guys have got this
weird rivalry with arsenal because you
had that in the 90s early 90s but the
fact the fact that liverpool and united
haven't really ever been on a level
pegging and yet have still been the
biggest game makes it absolutely the
biggest game yeah and that is why i do
100 agree but i just understand the
point of actually if you're watching the
game of for an entertainment value
you're going to see a united team
probably even lose to liverpool in this
moment or try and play on the counter
attack or whatever exactly but then when
you see all the entertainment value yeah
one for the little trolls but that's not
gonna happen this season
uh again
again don't happen again because we've
gotta play anfield soon so that's not
gonna happen
we've got ralph now he he set us up
tactically to not get beat five nil
come on
well we got there in the end is this
something we can agree on i i think so
yeah i did it yeah
you think your team that you played with
can be better than the team that i
played with yeah that can't happen what
is this england anyone you played with
oh yeah
[ __ ] i definitely won it
no i don't think i've got shira i've
gotten a lot
you got shearer have you no but i got
salah
how would you get him
frenzy